set your ovens to hot and get ready for
some manna robux because we have the
most insane episode of 1984 yet a lot of
our theories have come true so I'm here
to break it all down and what it could
mean for episodes to come you'll want to
stick around to the very end to see how
this season could link to Apocalypse Now
let's get into it
episode 4 true killer starts sometime in
the near past where Montana has a quick
pick-me-up before starting her class
we're at the perfect-10 aerobics studio
the same one we saw in episode 1 a not
creepy at all Rickie Ramirez watches
from the window and he either really
likes men doing aerobics or something
else has drawn him in when he enters
it's almost as if a combination of the
music and Satan have led him to Montana
whose quick to notice his knife Ricki is
training as well just not his cardio
Montana steps into the locker alone cuz
you know it's man aerobics and she's the
only woman there only to find the gutted
corpse of the Cyndi Lauper fan and
instead of screaming and running the
hell away she is kind of turned on by it
notice how he's strung up by these cords
the same that can be found on Ricky's
belts here and Ricky goes to town on her
feet
can I see your feet they engage in some
post-coital pillow talk which includes
arranging the murder of Brooke and yes
as I predicted in my last video Montana
is the brother of Sam the best man at
Brookes ill-fated wedding she believes
Brooke lied about hooking up with Sam
the night before the wedding an event
which caused Joseph to kill him now
she's hell-bent on revenge and bricky is
the one to do her bidding back in the
present Montana chastises Ricky for not
killing Brooke remember he's had two
opportunities to do it and she's gotten
away each time she tells them that they
have to do it fast
since jingles is around and then they'll
make their escape Trevor and Xavier have
somehow managed to get Chet out of that
pit of spikes and made their way back to
the infirmary
you're gonna be
nope no he doesn't
after he passes out they decided hit him
with some adrenaline which apparently is
some really good [ __ ] he tells him that
ray killed someone in college and Xavier
is like making porn was bad which
reminds him that Blake's Cadillac that
porn producer we met in episode 2 is
still somewhere nearby if they can get
Margaret and birdy and make their way
back to the car they have a way out so
Trevor and Xavier decide to split up and
look for them leaving Chet all alone
what could go wrong and I love how they
just give Chet a pair of scissors like
think thanks guys
Margaret finds the dead pranksters from
last episode which really can't be good
news considering campers are expected
tomorrow morning
trevor tries to get her to leave but
she's gone full crazy and says
everything's gonna be okay because she
has a gun the same gun we saw at the
beginning of episode 2 now when she
touches the blood on the body here she
gets a quick flashback is it from her
surviving the massacre or having done
the massacre we'll get to that in a bit
Xavier heads over to the mess hall and
bonus points have you picked up that HS
alum Stevie Nicks is playing on the
radio birdies they're making sandwiches
in the dark because you know that's what
you do when jingles comes in Xavier
hides under the bench and we learn a
little more about Margaret here birdy
called her a quote weird kid and says
that she lives in the past and wants to
be here for Margaret to help her turn
the page with camp redwoods revival
Xavier is a total dick dong and drops
his flashlight alerting jingles to his
presence birdy tries to save them but
both are knocked out and of course it
would be great if Xavier revealed
himself as Michael Langdon now so he
could survive the heat Brooke wakes up
in some sort of shed after she was
drugged last episode by nurse Rita
or should I say psychologist Donna
chambers remember that Rita and jingles
are working together and that she was
instrumental in his escape now Brooke is
able to get out of the shed pretty easy
but it doesn't take long for her to
spring one of those forest trap last
episode I predicted that it was Rita who
set these up since she would have had
time on like jingles to prepare the
grounds for their upcoming arrival in
episode 2 when jingles visits her she
would have likely told him where all the
traps are so he could both avoid them
himself and capture more victims
Rita spills the bee
and tells Brooke her entire plan and
uses Brooke as bait for jingles I'm a
scientist
you're my lab rat well jingles kill
indiscriminately or does he need the
thrill of the hunt last episode we saw
him leave the chubby prankster when he
could have easily killed him so his
motives to kill are still unknown and
rest in peace Xavier horn career I swear
if we have to watch Cody fern with
blisters in his face for the next six
episodes I'm not gonna be impressed but
faced with her dying strength Bertie
helps Xavier out of the oven and in an
act of mercy
Xavier puts her out of her misery chef
Bertie is good people and great his
fingerprints are gonna be all over that
knife Montana is outen aboot yes I'm
Canadian looking for Brooke when she
finds her in the trap Brooke tells her
all about Rita
I mean Donna when Montana says to hang
tight while she gets her something sharp
to cut her down
Ricky Margaret checks her gun when were
given this absolutely insane flashback
of her and jingles from 1970
notice the three counselors here who
make fun of her who are the same
counselors from the episode one Massacre
she's given a bear carving by jingles as
a symbol of strength then she goes on to
say this weird fact that bears mate for
life and oh oh god what are you doing
please no are you my bear Benji I do
anything to protect you
Ricky makes a pentagram seeking guidance
from the master Satan when Montana
directs him where to find Brooke jingles
arrives before Ricky can touch Brooke
and it seems as though he might have a
thing for saving defenseless women but
the most intriguing thing about this
scene is what Ricky says about the camp
saying that the blood spilled in this
place is eternal and no matter which way
you slice it mr. jingles lives forever
he's alluding to immortality and with
his death - jingles here and the fact
we've seen characters like the
hitch-hiker come back to life it's no
wonder he comes back at the end of the
episode during the scuffle rita montana
fight and Brooke manages to get away
Margaret's here praying for Cody fern to
get his burns healed when she's
confronted by jingles and we finally get
confirmation that she was the murderer
all along we get this flashback of
jingles being arrested and his Vietnam
ammo canister filled with severed ears
that were planted by Margaret here in
jingles cabin we can see her plant the
ears which also include
her own this [ __ ] took off her own damn
ear also little thing jingles also
carved a cute bunny
Margaret proceeds to tell him the truth
about what happened all those years ago
the amount of drugs and electroshock
therapy he went through made him forget
he had promised to protect her from the
bullies but did nothing so she took
matters into her own hands literally by
killing everyone making jingles take the
fall enraged by this revelation jingles
goes to kill Margaret but is shot by him
remember what Ricky said jingles is
eternal Brooke Trevor and Chet meet up
having heard the gunshots and for a guy
who's almost been killed a bunch he
makes sure to tell Montana who just
rolled around in the dirt fighting Rita
how gorgeous she is what's going on
ladies you are really manipulating men
this season although my favorite part of
this scene is when Trevor tells Montana
to take cheddar this [ __ ] rolls our
eyes anyways Trevor's off to look for
Margaret and oh oh no this this can't go
over well you actually killed him
Trevor sees that she's killed jingles
but it's too late right after he killed
you Margaret stabs Trevor having gone
full psychopath
God has given me the strength to accept
my true self she takes off his ear once
again to make it look like it was
jingles all along and speaking of which
he's disappeared as if Xavier night
couldn't get any worse he stumbles into
jingles and his weak ass tries to stab
him but we get this line from jingles
who's never made which could mean two
things either he's still processing the
revelation that he wasn't the killer or
that it was actually Margaret who
stabbed birdie to death and through
Xavier in the oven when they were both
unconscious I'll leave that one up for
you guys to decide
Brooke rushes in and jingles has once
again mysteriously disappeared almost
like he has some sort of teleportation
power two guys at the same time is he a
ninja they see an explosion off in the
distance which we find is their only
means of escape
Blake's Cadillac this is gonna be really
tough to clean up before the kids arrive
Margaret tells them that jingles
attacked her and Trevor died in the
process leaving the rest to process how
they're gonna get out of this mess and
now we have the coolest WTF moment of
the episode the resurrection of Ricky
Ramirez
[Music]
reto awakens from getting clobbered in
the head to find Ricki levitating in the
air and his wounds magically healing I
don't know about you guys but I got some
Exorcist vibes here he looks as though
he's possessed you can hear whispers of
people saying Satan and that combined
with the levitation but more interesting
are his black eyes now where did I see
that again I think this is huge proof
that we're gonna see a bigger connection
between this season and apocalypse and
if there's a connection to apocalypse
there's probably a connection to coven
now it's a bit too early to say what
exactly this connection is whether they
are somehow related or simply guided by
Satan but it sure would have been handy
for Papa Satan to resurrect his own son
last season as with many HS seasons a
lot of it comes down to taste but this
one is shaping up to be one of my
favorites
let's hope Brian Murphy and the team can
keep it up make sure to LIKE and
subscribe with the Belon because I'll be
coming out with more HS videos and leave
a comment about what you think about the
season below or send me theories on
Twitter
I think story YT until next time
remember daddy loves you very much